hace ya muchos vídeos realizamos una
introducción a lo que es la idea de las
proyecciones proyecciones y en aquel en
aquel entonces
lidiamos particularmente con
proyecciones sobre líneas que pasan por
el origen así que si tenemos una línea y
vamos a ir graficando esta idea si tengo
yo
primero voy a pintar los ejes
y ahí están los ejes y digamos que tengo
yo una línea
l esta línea l es el espacio vectorial
generado por un solo vector digamos por
el por el vector b estamos pensando
entonces que él es el conjunto de todos
los múltiplos de b y cuando digo todos
es pensar que lo multiplicamos por todos
los números reales verdad entonces si
nosotros tenemos por aquí a nuestro a
nuestra línea l que digamos que aquí
está mi vector b
y así seguimos construyendo todo este
espacio l
este es el y ahora nos tomamos un vector
x digamos
y se encuentre nuestro vectores y hasta
y aquí tenemos el vector x
un poco mejor la flecha ok este es
nuestro vector x y vamos a pensar o al
menos una forma en como me gusta pensar
a mí lo que es la proyección sobre una
línea es bueno pensar que aquí tenemos
el luz emitiéndose y esta sombra se
proyecta de forma perpendicular sobre la
línea entonces si se proyecta de forma
perpendicular estamos pensando que aquí
que aquí en este punto se encuentra la
proyección del vector x aquí está la
proyección sobre el espacio l del vector
x y de hecho lo definimos más
formalmente como si pensamos que x menos
la proyección sobre el sub espacio l es
ortogonal es ortogonal a cualquier otro
vector sobre el sub espacio el estamos
pensando en que esta diferencia es decir
el vector que va de uno al otro es
ortogonal o perpendicular a cualquier
otro punto sobre la línea y de hecho
teníamos una expresión muy agradable
para esto verdad
teníamos que la proyección sobre una
línea de un vector x de un vector x es
igual a x punto b y luego lo dividimos
entre b punto b que no es otra cosa más
que la magnitud de de al cuadrado pero
esto es un número escalar verdad esto
simplemente me dice que tanto tengo que
contraer o extender un vector y que en
este caso es b que es el que genera al
al espacio el de verdad entonces aquí me
está diciendo por aquí andaba nuestro
vector b este numerito me está diciendo
que tanto lo tienes que estirar o
encoger para conseguir la proyección de
x sobre el sub espacio ok entonces vamos
a hablar un poquito de de una definición
más general de proyecciones este es un
caso particular y es un caso particular
porque él es un sub espacio vectorial de
r n verdad por ejemplo aquí
pueden hacerlo fácilmente esto ya lo
hemos hecho y si tenemos dos vectores en
él la suma va a seguir siendo n l y si
tenemos un vector y lo multiplicamos por
cualquier escalar también va a poder
seguir siendo un vector que se encuentre
en el entonces realmente es muy sencillo
de ver que este es un sub espacio
vectorial válido y entonces vamos a
hablar de cosas un poquito más generales
un poquito más generales vamos a hacer
una pequeña separación si yo tengo b un
sub espacio un sub hoy un sub espacio
espacio de r n ok estamos pensando en un
sub espacio de rn también lo que sabemos
es que hay un sub espacio que existe y
que es el sub espacio ortogonal el
complemento ortogonal de b también es un
sub espacio verdad
déjenme poner el también también es
también es su espacio
también es su espacio ok entonces con
esto dicho también sabemos que si
tenemos cualquier vector en r n si nos
tomamos cualquier vector en rn sabemos
que lo podemos descomponer como una suma
es decir podemos escribir a x como ve
más w donde donde primero b se encuentra
en nuestro psuv espacio b&w se va a
encontrar en el complemento ortogonal es
decir donde ve el vector b se encuentra
en nuestro psuv espacio b mayúscula y w
se encuentra en el complemento [ __ ] no
no es w es en el complemento ortogonal
de nuestro psuv espacio ok entonces la
forma en que ahora voy a definir la
proyección sobre un sub espacio
cualquiera y arbitrario va a ser de la
siguiente forma la proyección sobre un
sub espacio
vector x dado que tiene esta única
expresión y de hecho demostramos en un
vídeo que es única entonces la
proyección simplemente va a ser la parte
de esta suma que se encuentra en el sub
espacio b entonces esto va a ser
simplemente b es quitarle esta parte que
se encuentra en el complemento ortogonal
de la misma forma pues uno podría
definir la proyección sobre el
complemento ortogonal de nuestro vector
x verdad en este caso vamos a quitar en
esta expresión la parte que no
corresponde al complemento ortogonal que
en este caso es b y por lo tanto sería
wv ok entonces esta definición resulta
ser equivalente con esta anterior en el
caso en que nuestro sub espacio
vectorial es una línea y vamos a revisar
un ejemplo que vimos hace ya algunos
vídeos hace ya algunos vídeos vamos a
repasar este ejemplo y vamos a usarlo
para ver que la solución o más bien
cuando cuando hicimos este ejemplo lo
que queríamos ver era
solución más corta de la ecuación a x
igual a b es decir la que tiene una
longitud menor verdad y nos dimos cuenta
además que ese elemento se encuentra en
el espacio fila aquí se encuentra el
espacio fila y bueno lo que queremos ver
ahora es que en efecto al menos
visualmente esas definiciones que vimos
anteriormente de proyección coincide
entonces déjenme déjenme a ir dibujando
ir dibujando estos espacios todos estos
conjuntos
vamos a poner primero unos ejes
ese día me fue un poco chueco
ok más o menos
y el otro
este
se me fue
vamos a poner este otro eje muy bien ahí
está entonces tenemos primero que nada
que el espacio nulo de la matriz es el
espacio generado por el 23 entonces si
yo me muevo 1 y 2 y luego me muevo 1 2 y
3 aquí se encuentra el vector que genera
este espacio y por lo tanto simplemente
tengo esta esta línea que resulta de
multiplicarlo por todos los escalares
posibles
ahí tenemos nuestro espacio nulo de la
matriz ese es el espacio nulo de la
matriz quien más tenemos el espacio fila
o que es lo mismo que el espacio columna
de la matriz transpuesta es el generado
por el 3 menos 2
entonces si ahora nos movemos hasta el 3
y luego bajamos 2 aquí tenemos el vector
que lo genera
y entonces tenemos todo este hoy eso no
se ve muy bien
todo este
espacio que es una
ahí está y más o menos se alcanza a ver
que son ortogonales digo aquí falla un
poquito del dibujo pero queda claro que
eran ortogonales verdad eso ya lo hemos
visto en varios vídeos de hecho si uno
quiere pues puede multiplicar estos dos
vectores que los generan y son y son
ortogonales pero bueno ahora ya que
tenemos eso esto lo que dije fue que el
espacio nulo el espacio nulo es el
espacio es el complemento ortogonal del
espacio fila es este complemento
ortogonal y por lo tanto también sabemos
que el complemento ortogonal del
complemento ortogonal es regresar al
espacio original entonces el espacio
nulo ortogonal el complemento ortogonal
del espacio nulo simplemente será el
complemento ortogonal de este que es el
espacio fila simplemente ambos son
ortogonales entre sí verdad entonces
como tenemos esta este esta expresión
esta esta igualdad de conjuntos en
realidad si yo me tomo cualquier vector
sobre sobre r2 digamos un vector no sé
aquí
ok entonces yo lo que puedo hacer es
descomponer ese vector como una suma de
dos de dos vectores donde uno se
encuentra en este de aquí que este de
aquí es el espacio fila y que sabemos
que es ortogonal el complemento
ortogonal del espacio nulo entonces de
esta forma podemos descomponer estos
vectores por ejemplo vamos a tener que
sumar este de aquí
en el espacio fila y cual vamos a tener
que sumar en el espacio del o más bien
el sub espacio nulo pues necesitamos un
vector más o menos así verdad entonces a
este vector lo podemos sumar de este
lado
y es como podemos descomponer cualquier
vector en r 2 en este caso como la suma
de dos vectores verdad como la suma de
uno que se encuentra en el espacio fila
y otro que se encuentra en el espacio
nulo en particular nosotros estábamos
buscando un una solución
estamos buscando una solución verdad
entonces el conjunto solución de esta
ecuación es el 30
ok aquí tenemos el 30
es el 30 para mí además me dice que hay
que sumarle todos los múltiplos del 23
entonces estamos pensando en una recta
que es paralela a nuestro espacio nulo
pero que pasa por el 23
ok esto ya lo habíamos hecho este dibujo
pero bueno si nunca está de más
repetirlo verdad ahora si yo me tomo
cualquier solución en este conjunto
digamos me tomo esta solución que
digamos que este es el vector s por ser
solución entonces sabemos que ese lo
puedo descomponer como la suma de dos un
r y un n perdón un n aquí es la suma de
dos vectores donde r lo estoy pensando
en el espacio fila o el espacio renglón
y n se encuentra en el espacio nulo de
la matriz entonces nuestra definición
nuestra definición de proyección nos
dice que la proyección la proyección
sobre el espacio fila de la matriz
r
perdón de ese ya estoy dando la
respuesta de ese pues justamente va a
ser el que se encuentra el que es en el
que se encuentra en nuestro espacio fila
que es r es verdad esa es la definición
que tenemos y eso coincide con la
solución más corta que teníamos de esta
ecuación es decir la que el conjunto el
elemento de las soluciones cuya cuya
longitud o cuya norma era la más chica
de todas las posibles y aquí se ve
geométricamente que esto es cierto
verdad entonces ahora nada más hay que
ver que si tenemos no sé cualquier
solución que se encuentre aquí y
proyectamos con la definición de
proyección sobre una línea que vimos acá
arriba coincide con el vector que
habíamos encontrado en aquel vídeo ok
entonces vamos a tomarnos una solución
cualquiera por ejemplo si aquí nos
tomamos alguno cuando se es igual a cero
tenemos que una solución es el 30
entonces x igual a 30 es solución es una
solución más bien es una solución de la
ecuación a x igual a b entonces qué pasa
cuando nosotros hacemos la proyección la
proyección sobre el espacio fila de la
matriz del vector 30 bueno vamos a
utilizar nuestra formulita que tenemos
acá arriba esta proyección es el vector
punto b sobre de punto b x b es muy
sencillo de acordarse entonces tengo mi
vector que es el 30
30 y voy a hacer un producto punto con
el vector b el vector b es el que genera
al espacio fila y el espacio fila está
generado por el 3 menos 2 que y entonces
estamos haciendo un producto punto con
el 3 menos 2 y ahora dividimos entre 3
menos 2.3 menos 2 y esto hay que
multiplicarlo por el vector
3 - 2 ok este es un escalar y este es un
vector vamos a ver qué es lo que nos
resulta de esto porque 3 por 3 es 90 por
menos dos es cero entonces todo esto
simplemente nos da 9 mientras que acá
abajo tenemos 3 x 39 y menos 2 por menos
dos es cuatro y nueve más cuatro son 15
perdón 13 son 3 déjenme ponerlo acá
abajo es 13 y aquí hay que multiplicar
por el 3 menos 2
entonces esto simplemente nos queda
13 a 29 sobre 13 de 32 que esto ya era
una expresión conocida y es familiar
verdad en el vídeo en que hicimos este
ejemplo justo obtuvimos esto y que si lo
si metemos esta constante en cada una de
las de la de las entradas de nuestro
vector tenemos 9 por 3 son 27 sobre 13 y
aquí es menos 2 por 9 son menos 18 sobre
3 muy bien entonces este vector es el
mismo que encontramos cuando lo hicimos
la primera vez en el vídeo en que
queríamos ver que éste era el de el de
mínimo tamaño verdad esto nos dice que
de verdad es consistente a la definición
que acabamos de dar anteriormente con la
definición que utilizamos aquí con la
definición de la proyección sobre una
línea
ok pero acá es donde tenemos las dos
definiciones ok acá arriba aquí arriba
está esta definición que estoy dando
estoy dando la definición de proyección
pero sobre un sub espacio cualquiera y
ya sabíamos hacerlo con una línea pero
aquí es para un sub espacio arbitrario
no importa cuál sea ahora no les he dado
una definición matemática agradable o
más bien quiero decir una forma
agradable para calcularlo y bien y ver
quién sería este vector b sobre el cual
o más bien sobre el cual estamos esté
más bien el cual es la proyección de
nuestro vector x no tenemos aún una
forma para calcularlo de fácil forma y
poder ver quién sería si si no fuera una
línea el sub espacio porque si es una
línea ya sabemos de hecho no he visto
mucho al respecto sabemos que cuando
tomamos la proyección sobre una línea es
una transformación lineal a que uno
puede verlo esto es una transformación
lineal pero no
mostrado que cuando tenemos una
proyección sobre un sub espacio
arbitrario y de hecho si va a ser lineal
pero lo haremos en el siguiente vídeo